[Music]
after all these years
there was nothing
until today
[Music]
all these signs
something bigger
maybe this is the point
this show is a drama
set against the backdrop of a massive
alien invasion of earth
one of the goals we had at this show is
to immerse the audience in a visceral
emotional
intense
survival situation we need to get home
the whole world is falling apart and
it's affecting people in different ways
everywhere it's incredible
it's amazing to see how the characters
evolve through this show
they're battling the elements and
trevontin a navy seal i mean he's seen a
lot of stuff
but to experience the fact that the
world's being invaded
that's new for everybody
invasion is a story about family it's a
story about our shared humanity all of
our characters are outsiders dealing
with their own version of alienation
we wanted all of these emotional stories
magnified by this global traumatic event
to be able to see the different vantage
points but everything is interconnected
the show is incredible
they're here
this is a very interesting show
it's much more than simple sci-fi come
on now
we don't know what it was
i think it's something you've never seen
before is super cool
it's the mystery it's what you don't
know
that's the scary thing
you